amen let's roll let's do it
team black for the win no pressure and
don't you dare tune in mute the stream
don't you dare be listening in
nimzo-indian land choppa licious d6v
five we've been here before
hang on let's try H six stop the bishop
nonsense
no nonsense bishop let's go night I was
gonna think I thought about Queen here
but then this eventual night maneuver to
a5 is not available I better do this
right now
so if pom push I can't go here but maybe
now I could let's do this right now
right now d5
now I could run here ah what's the scoop
it's castle it's my night gonna get
pinned
what's my LightSquared bishop wanna do
I'm asking a lot of questions do I have
all the answers no no I don't
Oh pine pushed night here night here c5
to ensue maybe I might have to worry
about a rook coming to the D file and
Knight coming to b5 and then D six maybe
I think I like it
this 94-95 a six and then c5 hang on
what's the plan here could I just maybe
target this pawn somehow kind of watch
out for Knight f5 nonsense too so as
soon as the Knights here I gotta do
something about that
maybe Bishop here is best
why can't it be easier if I play here
the Knights gonna kill me on this square
ah you're struggling
can you tell let's try this has to do
with sinking out this Knights
possibility of coming to b5 so push here
c5 I want to get those moves in and
chase the night to hopefully an
uncomfortable square that's my threat
okay let us see what white will do about
that he's six you better have a good
reason to do that now can you believe
that
I missed that there is this Knight move
but fortunately there's not a fork or
anything great takes takes Knight here I
have Queen c5 hitting the night and
watching over 97 forks oh the night is
going astray I think I'm liking my
position now let's do this and as a
follow up now Bishop f5 93 be very
scared be scared
I know why I say these things anyhow
Pond is defended now this guy is hit
right here defense it's in a pin as well
my knight pinned pin knight pin city
rook b7 get out of the pin guard ii
these rooks can't double for as long as
the knight is here okay I think this
makes life easier
let's see if I'm right is life easier um
I control f3 maybe I want to get my H
pun involved and I maybe want to do that
real soon
where does my knight want to live where
do you want to live Knight because
you're not doing a whole lot right here
are you know you want I have a great
number of squares cover let's try this
the entry points along this D file I
guess there is d6 mm-hmm
well I'm gonna try this actually remove
this Bishop and maybe look for a mate
fishing pole like stuff Oh going fishing
there might be a night repositioning to
this square but I would love to
reposition my knight to that square and
I'm a step in that direction right now
with this move but wait but wait there's
more
that's like an infomercial right there
but wait if you if you take now pawn
takes if I take with tonight there's a
rook here and I missed that
well here's the plan hopefully this pond
could be disruptive to the king and you
know now there's not gonna be a Cosi
flight square and I think as a prep move
I want to do this and there's no more
prep I gotta go quicker to this guy's
flying he's a flying player here I don't
have to react to that let's get on the
open file where else do I think I'm
gonna go with the rook okay let's go
Jeep on I might want to target h7 as
well King up to two reasons behind g6
watch over h5 f5 King g7 rook h8 ideas
supreme move that oh the night's gonna
be a serious problem isn't he oh I could
get the pond that was a slip that was a
slipper
I got h2 uh-oh bad news bad news bears
Knight here I actually thought about
Knight h1 can you believe that one
believe it
right here what is the story wow you're
my opponent do that on purpose was that
an on purpose right there
don't play king up if Knight takes pawn
here I give a check ruski followed by
this okay I think this is right I didn't
have to move my king by the way because
I could have always given check and then
picked it back off I'm gonna throw in a
check in now and wait a second I think I
could actually play a rook move here and
it's all the more appealing because of
made threats oh oh boy big trouble this
is a one King and pawn endgame actually
I'm seeing a variation where I could
liquidate every single piece all minor
pieces and the night at the end of it
all and end up with a three-on-two
majority and my king can sneak up here
and I could create a passed pawn even
though it is fractured somewhat even
though it's doubled so that's what I'm
looking into right now but is there
something cleaner rook check King here
rook check no actually I'm it's more
than that it's more than that it's I'm
actually winning a rook a full rook no
I'm not what am i doing i'm
miscalculating oh i gotta win this over
let me take the Queen whoa I can't be
right okay let's try this I gotta go
quicker I forgot there would be a night
block on d5 I missed that one is the
knight gonna give check I have
discovered okay let's run let's go King
that's a past Jeep on he's very valuable
uh-oh come over here King
let's watch over that there's not any
pod push that's actually nothing great
okay let's get on the open file go
quicker go quick g5f for g3 just get my
pawns rollin
let's go pawns king position rook
position pawn push let's do this one
first as soon as the King goes back my
King goes up King position box that came
out deadly fork on f3 big problems Wow
the rook can't move it's big trouble now
the rook moves I got this leading to me
no good solution tight right at the end
the King had to take flight there
good game Jonathan cm let us back up and
see how we can improve upon the things
either one of us let's see here
okay nimzo-indian land with just the
most direct a3 we have a compromised
structure and my opponent has what my
opponent has the bishop Peres
compensation so h6 to prevent the pins
and what was I don't know like um oh
this move right here I think what this
started yet really critical these next
few moves the knight move is off I think
I think the knight was off what might be
something better hmm
that night I'm just trying to kick it
away
c5 like I'm starting to feel really
comfortable right now
Knight in a good position this Knight is
floundering about so I'm wondering if
there's something earlier here hey six
seems a bit slow to be honest I Nick I
was expressing the thought you know I
don't want the night to eventually come
here after I kick it away and then play
here and after I play c5 I didn't want
it to make use of the b5 square but but
let's see is there something better
there's got to be something better right
hmm I wonder oh wow
well I think actually it turned out okay
this is right here like don't take my
knight that's one thing he can't move
anyhow he's pinned how about like what
did you eventually do it tonight you
played to f1 how about now how about now
you took the night and then you played
to f1 keep me in a pin be annoying to
your opponent and right now you're being
annoying to me your place you happy
you're having me in a pin I don't like
that so play to f1 and then look forward
to doubling on the deef I'll keep your
queen exactly where she is this is a
good spot for your queen when you played
to c2 right here I wasn't too concerned
about that what I'm most concerned about
is the following and that is this open
file and how I could very easily lose
control over it because of the pressure
that you can be maintaining on my b6 pun
should follow that by keeping pressure
on my b6 pawn it's going to make life
difficult for me right now to contest
this only open file so I think calmer
moves like just Knight here keeping me
in a pin and then doubling out the D
file I think I could really end up in a
difficult spot I think that would be an
improvement right here keep the pin by
default if you have your opponent in a
pin keep it
and that rule I think is also applying
in this instance